Here's the answer.
The chief financial officer is more than likely the economic buyer.
The saboteur might actually be the existing business intelligence group
inside of IT or the CIO's department
who is actually trying to already build the software,
and they might be afraid they're going to lose their jobs,
so in every major organization you might find people
who actually don't want or actively attempt to block a sale.
The CIO is more than likely the decision maker.
In some organizations they can actually sign off on large deals,
but in this case the chief information officer
is actually going to recommend to the chief financial officer
that they buy this software.
The report users, the people who actually use the product,
in this case they're just simply the influencers,
and that's kind of interesting to remember because
sometimes those entrepreneurs, we forget that the people
who use our product are not necessarily
the people who even pay for or even recommend the product,
and in this case the recommenders were probably
the line of business management, that is, those users
worked for a line of business, a division or a department,
and the influencers, the people who used it, said to their bosses
"We'd really like to have this software."
"This would work great."
And their managers, who didn't have any signature authority
or couldn't actually install software, recommended that
this actually get bought.
Understanding this ecosystem is really important
not only in business to business sales but sometimes
business to consumer sales as well.